it's time to turn that great idea you
have into a reality and you can do that
with Squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
with you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind
they've beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can make a beautiful website all
by yourself
but if you do get stuck they have 24/7
award-winning customer support that is
there to help so head to squarespace.com
slash Grace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain hello
and welcome to another episode of not
too deep I'm your host grace Helbig very
exciting episode ahead we have arielle
vandenberg and matt cutshall with us to
hilarious comedians content creators and
to people that have that classic romance
of being best friends and watching each
other date people for almost a decade
before realizing that they're perfect
for each other are now currently engaged
to each other that classic Hollywood
tale we learn all about coming from the
world of dance and the world of music
out to Los Angeles and their entire
comedic trajectory we also learn about
their new podcast and the fact that
Ariel has some privacy issues in the
southern hemisphere you'll hear all
about it enjoy this week's episode with
Ariel Matt
[Music]
I'm so excited that you guys are here I
want to know so many things about you
guys but one thing I do like to ask
people that are I guess hyphenated in
their their jobs is what's your deal how
do you describe what you guys do to
someone who doesn't know what's your
deal
you go first well I would like to call
myself an actress first and foremost but
I mean I haven't done an acting job in
years so I don't know if I claim actor
as my profession um I guess I am
god I am a content creator I make
content for myself I make content for
brands and then and then I I would like
to call myself a comedian I feel like
that's like a strong flame but you know
I I think I'm funny sometimes well the
thing is I mean you are a comedian
because you maybe because you say you
create comedy videos that more people
watch not to me you know it's funny
because that's what I want my title to
be like straight-up Romanian Berg
comedian but it's not weird because I
have the same thing where I get very
like kind of insecure about just
outright saying like I'm a comedian and
I don't know why I'm so like sensitive
about that for myself but it's like yeah
you're producing lols media does and you
are too so like we can just click on
ourselves comedians you know I think
they're like the weird part about saying
that is because you're never nobody but
the only people that say they're funny
are not funny people so very true I
never want to be like well I'm just kind
of funny cuz like a person isn't funny
usually so totally I totally get it
yeah and also it's hard to claim being a
style medium and you've only done it
like 10 times in your life so you did a
good job I just said I did a great job
does that mean I did a horrible job you
know and for myself you know kind of
similar answer I'm a content creator you
know I make content for myself
and for brands and that kind of you know
creating content online just turned into
me becoming an online comedian so I
guess that's essentially I'm a comedian
too we're comedians we're all comedians
here but we got there we got there I'm
also body builder they I've seen there's
all these - Asians you guys have all of
it the so you guys take me back to when
you guys started out in Los Angeles I
also like to would love to find out
because you guys are engaged as a
relationship couple do you remember the
first time you met each other and I'm
curious if you guys have different
points of view on that experience I
don't remember it okay no you actually
do gonna say if you know our story that
we don't we tell well you are a good
actor amazing okay get hired so the very
brief story is so I moved in LA in 2006
I met her just a few months later I met
you at the very beginning of 2007 yeah I
was really close with one of my friends
Riley and she took me to her friend's
house because we were all gonna like
pregame before we go out her friend's
house was her then-boyfriend
so it was us I was me my friend Riley
Arielle and her boyfriend and that's how
we met Wow we obviously you know we
definitely like hit it off that night
and had a good time but not hit it off
like you know like you guys like we know
I was little I left that night being
like I think I have a new best friend
like I was told me like girls yeah we
became friends immediately but you know
not to the point where we exchanged
numbers and started hanging out we
started hanging out kind of like a
couple years later but yeah it was just
a random night where I met her you know
through my friend and yeah that's fine
yeah and but I like that it was so pure
that you were like we're best friends
now
this is sweet and then cut to how many
years later is that 14 years later or
something we
we started dating three years ago I'm
sorry dating three years ago yeah
because we just had our three year thing
so we were a so we were so wait so we're
right so we've been dating for three
years and engaged for eight months maybe
Wow something wrong oh cool so okay so
what's the without being you know - you
don't to be too detailed what's the step
in taking it from friendship to
relationship where one horse you gotta
intercourse it got it okay I mean I know
honestly like if I could simplify that
answer just be that timing like yeah
timing is so big with anything that has
to do with relationships I feel like but
especially with us because you know I
had I had boyfriend after boyfriend
after boyfriend and then you know he was
single the whole time waiting but I I'm
kidding oh did that just hurt you hurt
she was like oh my god joking yeah so
like we both were in relationships on
and off for the whole time we were best
friends and Wow and then when we were
both you know in our 30s and realizing
like oh my god you're right there this
whole time well that's for me kind of
yeah it's such a movie moment situation
dude like I was I'm living a fairy tale
because you know what so crazy I always
thought no I can't like because everyone
would always ask me like are you are you
in Matt ever gonna date or are you guys
dating secretly and whatever yeah and I
was always like no like I wanted my like
fairytale to be that like this Parisian
man was gonna sweep me off my feet you
know whatever but I didn't realize that
the fairy tale that I really wanted was
like that I was going to end up with my
best friend
and that's so cool and now that's my
fairy tale like I don't want to not
understand my Parisian boyfriend like
I'd rather be talking to you all the
time yeah it is
I I'm
I am seen amongst my friends who are
getting older like me and now in our 30s
they are actually ending up with friends
there any people who were their close
friends back then and not just someone
random that they met like on a nap so I
feel like in our 20s is just being young
enjoying LA and all the hundreds of
thousands of similar people like you and
yeah and then just enjoying dating
around but um yeah I think that like
what really matters the most is someone
that you love to death connect with and
I think marrying your best friend is
just like the dream come true I think
that's the coolest [ __ ] thing thank
you guys I mean but also I'm sure like
as soon as you start making it public
and audience is like no [ __ ] you guys
like we've been watching this happened
the whole time are our own best friends
were like yeah duh and we're like oh no
it's it's so cool and like honestly
timing was really it because we we just
needed to be in that same exact moment
at the same exact time and go totally
yeah yeah and also and it takes like
some courage because you have to take
the risk right because you're like a
best friend that you're like if this
doesn't work out oh oh that was my whole
thing is I either try with Matt but
there's no trying when you're that close
like we would we literally hung out
every every day so like so like you
don't try with someone like that you
either get married to them or you never
talk to them ever again or you or you
stay best friends yeah I can't just
casually date him like he would know
that I'm dating other people you know
like you do that so I was like I'm
either all-in on this or you know or we
just stay friends and I'm so glad I let
myself do what my heart told me to do
cuz now we're engaged and I'm I like
I've never like I've never had a
relationship that's been so like
trusting and per like he's the most
helpful
you're just you're you're my person my
person yeah I mean you guys have been I
mean you've been best friends for so
long so it's like the hardest part of
the relationship the friendship you
already had down to like
um I want to go back a little bit before
you guys or like right when you guys
were coming to Los angeles-area you were
a dancer and Matt you were a singer yeah
I mean were you in a boy band of some
yeah
yes made it sound like a stripper I was
saying yeah would you said dancer I was
like [ __ ] I don't know I did yes keep
going okay I moved to LA for all of
entertainment business but I really
wanted to be a musician so I started a
band and toured in a band for the first
like four or five years of being in LA
so that's what I originally came to LA
for Wow have you what was the premise
and like how did you start the band did
you just find a group of friends and was
like this is it here we go kind of so I
had like how do you start a band or some
other options right now it's honestly it
was so fun and and some of the best
times of my life was torn with these
guys I'm from Portland Oregon two of my
best friends Judah and duck are also
from Portland Oregon and their brothers
they played on attack
Judah and duck they played in bands
literally since they were probably like
11 years old like they were in like
cover bands and they were just really
good musicians okay I had this ideas
like hey guys I'm moving to LA and I
really think that we have a shot at
starting like a kind of like a punk rock
pop you know boy bands like a fusion
band and they're like we're so down they
moved to LA with me and then we had to
find two other people to fill guitar and
bass and we just started reaching out to
people like just our friends and say hey
do you or any of your friends know a
really good guitarist or a good basis so
we scouted for the other two guys and
then we formed our band and then we all
- started like fishing in money and
recording and I mean we just we did it
from the ground up very like okay what
are we gonna name our band what are we
gonna sound like how can we work with
bigger people and I think what really
how we really got lucky is our first
song we recorded ended up being big on
MySpace so the golden years the golden
years of musics
Tila Tequila yeah so we had this song
called Miss Hollywood that was just
super fun and catchy and a lot of like
the scene girls on MySpace
we're posting it on their profiles
calling themselves Miss Hollywood and so
we ended up getting millions of plays on
there and then everyone started having
interest from producers and and and
writers and other people who wanted to
work with us and that kind of like you
know that kind of got us really moving
but you know it's obviously it's hard to
work and we had to write the song but it
is a little bit of that luck where it's
like we got lucky that that one song hit
at the right time
totally when was there a dramatic
disbanding of the band when you all went
in separate ways or was it kind of less
unnatural dissolving like we're all
doing different things now so it's
actually going are you guys no no no I
was gonna say it's actually pretty
traumatizing story not not really but
like it's not really a good aggressive
word to me listen to me it was dramatic
no trauma talking I was traumatized
because all I wanted to do was be a
successful musician
and we were right there so this long
story short would be we were on the rise
getting on bigger tours are one of our
songs hit radio and you started climbing
the charts on radio and then we started
getting multiple label offers from
bigger labels that because we were
signed to an indie label yeah and then
we had two big offers one was really
really good and we wanted to go with
that one our label our indie label was
started getting like all greedy and like
holy [ __ ] like no we're gonna wait for
literally a million dollar deal back
then that wasn't happening like people
weren't signing for a million dollars
unless you were Drake I think Drake did
a million-dollar deal and LFO or not LFO
lfm oh you know you know a song party
rock party yeah so like massive Bay acts
were being signed for that our label was
like we're gonna wait for that we're
like we're not there dude we're on the
rise you have to let us upstream to
another label uh they long story short
they said no they said we're gonna wait
for
better deal they wouldn't fund us
anymore they wouldn't give us money for
tour so we had we sat on this label that
wouldn't let us upstream
show and we were shelves and I was like
well what am I gonna do
locked in a contract yes people that
wouldn't let you leave and it's just so
shitty yeah we couldn't get on bigger
tours we couldn't pay for bigger tours
because you do have to say and our album
that we had spent a lot of money on in
time was now like like a last year thing
and it just it just slowly started
dissolving like that so there was never
like a we breakup we're done with this
we were literally on the way and then
our label just held us and we couldn't
go any further
so that's what yeah so I always wonder I
I just you know it makes me wonder what
could have happened like right I'm a
really hard worker and if I put my mind
into stuff I know I can make it happen
so in my mind I'm like [ __ ] I would be a
touring artist right now but I mean
optimistically speaking I feel like you
guys both have the very much like hard
work ethic where like you have created
opportunities for yourself because
things like labels and things like you
know Hollywood have gatekeepers that
keep you from being able to do
everything you want to do such a thing I
feel like that might have helped
strengthen you guys and going to like
because you went from there to like to
vine in that whole world that just
fostered a community of like creatives
doing their own thing yeah no but you're
right I truly believe in that I believe
that like you know I was brought to
where I am now for a reason if things
just weren't met you know they didn't
work out for a reason and it's totally
fine and and yeah I'm happy with why I'm
now but it is kind of crazy like that
the twists and turns that Hollywood
throws at you because everyone most
people move here for one thing end up
doing another that might not work out
and then they end up way over here it's
very strange very strange also is there
an opportunity for the band to get back
together at the wedding oh my god
that would actually be hilarious funny I
owned it out there I thought it's a it
could be a great moment I am down no
joke if I had more time on my hands than
I do now I would literally take the time
to get the band back together
practice and actually just do a reunion
show like a one time reunion show and
release maybe a song like it's it's
still a passion I love doing music it's
just so much damn work to get it off the
ground that getting us back together
would be pretty tough
totally totally um an area you came from
not specifically dance but you have
dance in your background and was that we
were like looking towards when you got
here you came to Los Angeles we wanted
to act no okay so I did ballet and like
danced my whole life growing up okay and
through high school and stuff like that
but that's what kind of made me want to
be like a performer I didn't I I always
kind of thought like oh I'll go off and
do I wanted to go being a company and
like maybe move to New York and being a
ballet company but I was so tall and all
the ballerinas word way shorter and way
lighter than me and like I was like okay
I'm not gonna compete with like this
stick like so tiny you know yeah I'm
like and I was I was small but I was
taller and so I was just like okay what
else can I do okay I'm gonna be a backup
dancer so I like honestly thought I
wanted to like backup dance for Britney
oh yeah or people like I I was like that
would be so fun to go on tour I actually
thought about that a lot but my main
thing that I really wanted to do was be
on SNL like that was my I was obsessed
with Jim Carrey I was like obsessed with
Martin Lawrence like all the you know
like all the MADtv in living color
frickin SNL people I was obsessed with
all of that and I was like okay I really
want to do something like that
but I just I think my my idea of that
was okay go to LA and get into improv
classes which is exactly what I did when
I was around 17 18 I started going to
improv class is going to Groundlings
and all those things but obviously doing
that doesn't pay anything
no I pay you have to pay out of pocket
to do that it's oh why yeah and I
literally moved to LA with $0 so I I
started modeling cuz I was like okay
that those are jobs that you can get a
little bit sure I mean a little bit
easier than acting jobs so I started
modeling doing like catalog work and
just saving my money and started going
to improv classes and really trying
towards that yeah and it was a lot it
was obviously a lot harder than I
thought to get to a place where you're
even in like the Writing Lab class of
Groundlings I don't know if you did that
stuff but no I did stuff in New York but
yeah I know what you mean where it's
like you have to work and pay so much to
just get a seat at a table that might be
kind of near a table that everyone else
is that but you don't know for sure
it's crazy exactly exactly so like I was
in this weird place where I was like
okay it's been five years that I'm doing
improv now like and I've done nothing
with improv okay so I just started I got
an agent and a manager for acting
randomly like it sounds sketchy but it
was I met this manager at at coffee bean
he like comes up to me okay I was
probably 18 years old I'm gay I'm at
coffee bean I was commuting from San
Diego to LA like just to go to auditions
so I would sit at Coffee Bean and wait
for traffic to be over because I would
just drive after traffic right so I was
sitting at Coffee Bay in this like old
man comes up to me and he's like hey are
you an actress and I like I'm I was very
aware of everything like I know if
someone was being creepy I knew if
someone was like trying to hit on me
whatever this dude just wanted to like
work with me I could tell cuz I had the
opposite where they're like hey you're
an actress I'm like get away from me
totally um you know there's that side of
it this guy was like a sweet old man he
was like are you an actress because you
should be and I was like wow I would
love to be an actress yeah and so I told
my mom and then my mom hit him up and
anyways I started working with this
random guy
freaking coffee bean he like worked out
of his house I never I never went to his
house never was like weird he just would
give me auditions my first audition from
him was for The OC so I was like oh
you're legit gotten red for oh my god
I'm blanking on me no no it was way like
he was way into the series like series
12 I was like auditioning for Mischa
Barton 'he's little sister's best friend
or something you know like something
stupid like stillage it stillage is
still legit because I auditioned for oh
my god I'm blanking on the creator's
name and that's bad because I love him
oh my god John anyways doesn't matter do
I wish for him and I was like this is
big stuff you know so anyways um and I
just kind of went from there and just
started acting and fell in love with
acting and and and wanted to do stand-up
and I don't know I feel like I'm at a
point now where SNL would be really cool
to do but I'm now not wanting to move to
New York as much as I thought I would
when I was in my 20s
oh yeah all of Hollywood has changed
dramatically and you guys are doing
really cool stuff right now that's
taking up a lot of time that I'm gonna
ask you about after we take this quick
break so we'll be right back with more
not too deep I believe it is about time
to turn that dream into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're looking to start a new
business showcase your work published
content sell products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you with
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself plus they have a
powerful ecommerce functionality that
lets you sell anything online and
analytics that help you grow your site
in real time everything is optimized for
mobile right out of the box there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever
whatever that means finding domains is
super simple and you can get all the
help that you need with Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support
power millions of people from designers
to lawyers to artists to gamers
restaurants gyms and now you so head to
squarespace.com such grace for a free
trial and when you are ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain again that squarespace.com slash
grace offer code grace well okay let's
talk about where you guys are at now
what you're working on one you guys have
a podcast together which is really sweet
because it's a feat to be dating someone
and engaged just someone in Hollywood
but then to also continuously work
together like great job we'd you know
it's crazy we do everything together
that is crazy but that's but like good
for you have you guys developed a set of
like tools or skills to understand like
when you've either crossed the line
unlike a creative idea or like has it
just always been pretty symbiotic of you
guys working together to be honest I
feel like it's it's it's been very easy
to work together because we do have the
same humor yeah and we both add to each
other's you know skits and ideas and and
creative so we've never really had an
issue on the creative side like which is
honestly shocking because I'm a very
independent person you're a very
independent person but we just I don't
know we just we collab pretty well yeah
that's great so where did the podcast
idea come from I had a podcast called
the only child and I was doing that
right before I did right before I
started love Island so like to almost
whoa two years ago no way
yeah I'm oh yeah like a year and a half
ago I had those podcast and I I realized
that every episode that I liked doing
was when he was my guest we just had so
much fun and I had a I had a co-host on
there - his name is low and he was I
mean he's so funny and so amazing but
whenever Matt was on it was just like
the most fun episodes for everybody so I
was like and then at home you can do a
podcast from home so it's like it's a
it's a
another creative outlet that we we were
like okay we've done Instagram we're on
Twitter we do YouTube
let's do podcast like everybody else
like literally like everyone's doing
podcast but yeah who cares it's you can
do it from the comfort of your own home
we bought all the gear and so it's yeah
for you guys especially because you you
create so much stuff that's edited that
it must be nice to be able to have just
an unedited conversation with each other
without working out like and and I don't
we don't like cuss on our instagrams
we're pretty family friend friendly I
can't even yeah it's like your body's
rejecting that idea we we don't cuss on
there and I just like let loose on my
podcast where I like I'm like I mean
it's not really not the best thing but
it yeah you you're more free to be
honest to be yourself and not really
care like yeah cuz the thing is we do
have to watch you know you know for the
for our brand partnerships that we have
yes to watch what you say and like how
you you know you don't want to cuss too
much you don't want to like have to like
risque of humor yeah so I like it's fun
to just kind of like be ourselves on our
podcast and just do our thing and you
guys have each other's back so it's nice
to be able to have like someone else's
point of view on things and be like yeah
being too much oh we do that all the
time I'm like you should probably cut
that part out let's talk about love
island congratulations this is so cool
and so for people that don't know you're
the host of the US version of love
island yeah so cool what was that whole
experience that process like um okay
it was awesome i I got called in for
this freaking show that I I had heard
about and I had never seen it and I
remember being like love island okay so
I went on Hulu or something wherever
they play the UK version the UK version
is huge and I you know I watched it and
I was like dude this show is bananas and
I'm like I need to book this and so I
ended up I so glad I booked the job I
went to Fiji
was there for about I think like seven
weeks or something I don't know every
time I say it I'm always like nine weeks
ten weeks to let like I don't remember
how seven one six I don't I mean we're
there for long seven weeks so went to
Fiji it's so funny like it's so cool
meeting the whole cast that they all the
people that got cast in it all the
Islanders and oh yes people that don't
or might not be familiar with the show
how do you describe it so it's a I mean
if I was to describe it not CBS its ace
it's it's honestly like um like a
romantic comedy reality show but it's
yeah in in enjoyment not only because
it's not just like meet the love of your
life potentially it's like people become
best friends on this island it's a
dating show in a you know in theory but
it's like it's a it's a it's it's five
single girls five single guys they meet
on an island they have to basically
couple up with each other they sleep in
the same bed from the from night one you
know if you're coupled up with someone
you sleep in the bed with them it's like
it sounds really intense
mine too they don't have cell phones
they don't have TV they don't have
movies you only have so they only have
they only have time to get to know each
other and that's what's so cool about it
is like they become absolute best
friends or they get in a relationship
where they fall in love because you all
you have is time to invest in one
another that's pretty cool yeah yeah
it's it I mean it's a bonkers like
social experiment for everyone
especially because we're so dialed in
and tied to every ounce of Wi-Fi that we
can get and you have when you're like
stripped of all of that and have you
like communicate as a human hiding well
I fell in love with three of the
Islanders - you did - yes my gosh and
honestly no but no joke the best part I
I got a I got hooked like obviously like
I was there with her and I was watching
like what was happening live and I got
hooked and suddenly everyone is suddenly
coupled up and things are smooth and
going great and they're like I love you
I love you too then they drop off three
more hotties on the beach who come in
like oh [ __ ] there's more hot girls and
hot guys it's really cool it's really
good what was the wildest thing that
happened this past season like I'm sure
there's just so much to process so many
like no no Westin did something he was
always doing something I know but was
that everyone was pissed about what was
that no I think no well hey Oh God good
question I'm having flashbacks right now
I think like the craziest thing that
like the most drama that actually
happened was there was a guy on there
named Gaiman and I love a gay man he was
so cute he was so funny he's like so
charming and he had like three girls but
all really liked him and none of them on
that the other one like them and then it
was just like this whole thing and then
that blew up in his face and then like
the people like hated him and I'm like
no he's actually loved anything but
people you know people started getting
super mad at him because he was like
playing all these chicks and I'm like
that's what this shows for right all
right that's probably the most drama
that really happened I mean this one
girl came in she was like how dare you
do this to me remember Ilana yes no cuz
she fell in love with Yemen ooh there's
some tough tough and it's also like your
job must be so hard to not get too
emotionally attached Oh everyone I cried
when when the first guy left when
Michael left yeah honestly I was like I
was like Michael your time on the island
is over and the producers in my ear and
she's like are you crying and I was like
you're crying but the reason why is
because it was our first elimination or
like kicking someone off and I was
nervous as a host I was nervous because
technically we're live you know I mean
like we're kinda like we are shooting
everything it's not like hey cut let's
do a it's like he is sad that he's
leaving so I'm standing next to this
crying person who's not fake crying and
I'm just like I'm like okay I have to
tell him oh god it was hard
that's devastating okay is there a
reality show that the two of you guys
would compete on together like Oh
amazing you know you saw something
yeah like Amazing Race like survivor
like supermarket sweep any that like
really you guys would dominate on I
would dominate on Dancing with the Stars
there you go I want you so bad in my
friend do you know Kaitlyn Bristowe yeah
she was supposed to podcast with us
today but she just got Dancing with the
Stars and yeah oh my god full-body
chills I'm so excited I'm like I love
wet cuz I'm friends with Derek Hough we
are and so watching him you want him to
win you know but since he's not on it
anymore I'm like now I have like a
reason to watch I'm like Kaitlyn has too
so excited so I would love to be on
Dancing with the Stars but also we could
do The Amazing Race I'm not gonna eat
snails or anything but I would love to
do that show with you that'd be so fun
yeah yeah I feel like you guys would
have a great time doing it because you
know if I was survivor I would die okay
how was camping this was an attempt to
just kind of like get away from the
world for a little bit and like
decompress yes it was it okay it was fun
so so I for years literally years I've
been wanting to get a rooftop tent for
my Jeep it's unlike my dream I'm like
the second I saw them come out with
those I was like I need to have one
so obviously it's expensive to get the
rack in the tent and I kind of like just
waited for the right moment to actually
like like spend on that and like give
myself I did that a few months ago and
then the pandemic hit and I'm like this
there's no better time to leave town
than right now so we're like let's get
out of here we drove to Utah we had
friends come from Boulder Colorado so we
kind of met in the middle and we I mean
when I say we went off-grid we were on
the top of a mountain where there
weren't any there weren't trails anymore
like our big my Jeep that got stuck a
couple times and we had like it was like
we went off-grid to where we
didn't see anybody and it was but
weirdly we had service at the top
Mountain we had like kind of bummed
because I'm like oh well we'll go up
there we won't have service you know you
get up there and I'm just on Instagram
to show my top package yeah that's very
fun but also as soon as you get your
Jeep stuck you're like is this how it
ends for us was this worth it yeah is it
worth it I mean I want to pretend like
I'm obsessed with camping I liked it and
it was fun but I I'm definitely not like
I made him bring a privacy tent for me
so that I could do things yeah you know
just gonna like walk out in the middle
of nowhere dig a hole like I'm not doing
it we were in the middle of nowhere I
don't care no neighbors no houses no
people no other campers and she's still
wanted to put a privacy tent away from
Camp to do her business and I'm like are
you kidding me just go dig just go dig a
hole no one's gonna see you well we were
with our friends and Sophia show like
she literally leaves for an hour and I'm
like and she just walks back casually
with like her like wipes or whatever
then walking back I'm like this [ __ ]
just went into the freaking trees and
pooped and no one's asking her about it
I'd rather be asked about it like so
she's like a tent shaking around and you
know I'm in there yeah things are
happening so I yeah that was that was
the I don't think I could have done it
without a privacy tent so girls if you
like wanna try camping legit get a
privacy tent it will change my life I
will never go camping without that
luxury oh I'm with you I I just like the
psychology of knowing that a snakes
gonna not jump up and bite me in the
butt hall in a situation is a little bit
more comforting it's not even about like
bugs or snakes it's about like someone
that's like I'm gonna sit here with a
telescope and wait wait till I see it's
like a person from far away
I think someone with a telescope is
gonna see my butthole and
this speaks to some maybe Los Angeles
paranoia that's been building manager at
coffee bean so hey um do you guys prank
each other often or attempt to you know
not I hate not a full-blown prank but we
do kind of mess with each other like I
will do things to kind of surprise her a
little bit and like we're very goofy
together and we'll kind of shock each
other with what with being silly but not
not like actual pranks right not not
like I got you a moment not no okay
that's good good for you guys that'll
keep it safe and healthy relationship
yeah I'm so glad he doesn't like scaring
me like I had I'm scared and I had a
boyfriend I had a boyfriend that would
scare the [ __ ] out of me like every day
and I'm like what does that do for you
like yeah exactly
it you took like one time I was like if
you ever scare me again we're done like
we are so done like I'm we're breaking
up and I and he scared me so bad that I
broke up with him you're like I'm true
to my word I'm gay I'm communicating in
the most honest way I possibly can with
you right now so true that's wonderful
okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back I want to hear
everything that's coming up in the
future all the future camping trips
everything we'll be right back with more
not your date okay before we hear about
what's coming up in the future I'm gonna
ask you guys the two questions I asked
every single guest that is on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti act ooh
throw cold spaghetti at yes
and this is an answer that can change on
a regular basis because you might have
someone one day that you want to throw
it up more than someone else another day
no it doesn't like it hurts it doesn't
it's not like it hurts them doesn't just
and just like it's up to you what your
intention is it can be like a
celebratory thing I know what it I got
mine okay mine would be I want to throw
cold spaghetti at the famous tick-tock
boys with broccoli hair that's good the
famous tick-tock boys that have the
dangly earrings in the broccoli hair and
they're all like dancing all sexy I
would love to just grab a pile of
spaghetti and just throw it at them they
would be like now I want to go yeah I've
only made them stronger oh gosh that's a
good answer I feel like I want to go
with well ok only if Nick Jonas and
Priyanka Chopra posts any more wedding
photos I know well they did for a long
time I'll but I am so obsessed with like
think their wedding was so beautiful I'm
like can I copy your wedding but at the
same time like we saw another photo the
other day I was like no they also had
like six weddings yeah they had a lot of
celebration we just freaking like my
dream I'll I'm a celebrator of life and
so like for them to be able to do that
I'm like I want that much money that'd
be sick you know so like just out of
jealousy I'd throws cold spaghetti out
at those two lovebirds great lovely no
worries yeah they're avid listeners of
this podcast they're gonna respond
immediately guys here yeah be on our
podcast ok the other question is every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or like a close
call Wow that's mouth sorry but you can
only use 3 words or three small phrases
so
mine so like or a combination mine is
college jogging front lawn okay oh yeah
okay mine is it's real bad so you say
yours what yours was what cabin jogging
yours is what mine was College hogging
front lawn okay
mine was cabin Oh panic kitchen the
kitchen the place where food is made and
stored at a fourth in front of three
girls okay
oh no that's like a horror film is mine
mine would be wait so what so what it's
like the location no you just say it's
just work you can just do like small
phrases or three words whatever makes
most sense to you
okay got it I'm gonna go with okay
germaphobe I don't go in public
restrooms I don't know how to phrase
that in know one thing and traffic
didn't do it like it was a bad day for
my rectum let's put it that way
wow wow I've experienced that level of
chaos in my body so I was literally like
I've been it like I went to an audition
and I was like Rick I have to take the
freakin 10 home and it was a like or
what's it called trap what's the traffic
hour called we got a shower rush hour
was in rush hour traffic
well like oh thank you like rush hour my
butthole I'm saying I'm in worse I don't
know I'm being gross oh it's great no
that's um
those are the moments where I feel like
I can have mine control over my body and
I'm like I'm so if I just think that I
can do it I can do it and it's not
always the case
okay before we wrap everything up
usually when we do the podcast in person
we like to give our guests a gift for
making time for us and we usually give a
personalized fortune cookie but because
we're doing it digitally we have a
digital fortune cookie for you guys that
I believe melissa is sending to you or
has sent to you okay got it
please open when grace asked you to well
you just did so here we go Maya fortune
cookie says apartments sorry
we're little two for Klimt to get this
fortune cookie written out maybe come
back later when we're a little less for
Klimt Wow so we'll come back later
that's all right just to be on your
podcast again ever way I'm just really
wanting us to be your co-hosts just come
back people to talk to you guys I need
people to talk to you thank you a late
to give a little silly thing that's a
fun at the end where can people find
everything that you guys are up to and
are there any major things coming up in
the future you got your podcast now
what's what's going on you can listen to
our podcast it's called riled up with
Arielle and Matt and then hopefully my
season 2 of love Island will be coming
out shortly here probably towards the
end of the year I mean maybe September I
actually don't know hopefully I'll get
those dates soon um
CBS and then yeah I'm on instagram at
Arielle or tik-tok if you want to follow
my dancing yeah what is it the Arielle
honestly I think the best way to find us
if you google Arielle and Matt all our
stuff pops up you can find all yeah if
you do then you'll see our stuff and
yeah check us out we like we like making
comedy skits we like podcasting and
having fun conversations so we're
to entertain you guys love it well good
luck with the wedding planning I can't
wait for the band to get back together
and very exciting things on the horizon
for you very exciting thank you go check
everything out you guys I will see you
next time I don't have episode of not
too deep goodbye goodbye to these 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer Melissa D
months edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]